apertura de este encuentro por parte del
canciller argentino Santiago cafiero
Argentina todavía tiene la presidencia
pro tempore del mercosur que le cederá
en este encuentro a Brasil Él hizo un
resumen de la presidencia pro tempore de
Argentina pero también habló de la
importancia de profundizar la
integración regional y diría que el tema
central como bien lo mencionabas tiene
que ver con este acuerdo entre Unión
Europea del mercosur que no termina de
concretarse sobre eso cafiero dijo que
estuvo frenado más por las diferencias
al interior de la Unión Europea que por
otra cosa también dijo que hay que
actualizar los textos originales de 2019
para equilibrar la situación entre
bloques desiguales la Unión Europea y el
mercosur y dijo sobre todo que le
preocupan las nuevas demandas
ambientales de la Unión Europea
presentadas en un borrador de este año
al que el mercosur debe responder Me
parece que esos son los ejes centrales
de la presentación del canciller cafiero
en esta jornada de lunes y Qué
propuestas o acuerdos Se esperan ya de
la Cumbre de líderes de mañana
de lo que veníamos hablando ya se
desprende un poco de que Irán estas
discusiones en las que se reúnen por
primera vez desde 2019 los cuatro
presidentes de los países integrantes
del bloque Alberto Fernández por
Argentina Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva por
Brasil Luis la calle puedo por Uruguay
Mario abdo por Paraguay hizo sucesor el
presidente electo Santiago Peña y si
hablarán sobre todo cuestiones
comerciales el acuerdo con la Unión
Europea pero también eventuales posibles
acuerdos con otras regiones o países por
ejemplo con china ahí hay que ver si se
alcanza un acuerdo que permitan algún
momento avanzar en negociaciones y
también está la posición de Uruguay que
es conflictiva y polémica al interior
del bloque porque Uruguay quiere
negociar por su cuenta algunos de estos
acuerdos bilaterales por ejemplo con
China y eso no se lo permite en las
reglas actuales del mercosur por eso
pide flexibilizar Esas reglas
seguramente eso también se estará
discutiendo el martes